loin des voitures si un jour vous
arrêter à l'auberge de les rides dans à
veyrier du lac en savoie et bien vous
rencontrerez là un très bon chef il
s'appelle marc veyrat sa spécialité à
lui ce sont les herbes et les plantes de
la montagne qu'il va accueillir très
régulièrement car avant d'être cuisinier
marc veyrat lui et était berger
reportage marie-pierre samitier frédéric
faure d'avril à septembre
marc veyrat se lève avec le soleil et
monte à 2000 mètres dans les alpages
il parie cueillir les plantes dont il a
besoin pour ses cuisines jeu sert pollet
chaînon on l'appelle le pape yowlè il y
a donc le thym sauvage mais aussi la
sauge et la chicorée toutes ces plantes
dont il connaît par coeur de secret
depuis son enfance par la racine de
chicorée exceptionnel laquelle je vous
avais commencé à garder des moutons au
j'avais sept ou huit ans ces chapeaux ce
chapeau c'est quelque part le patrimoine
qu'est ce que je peux préserver de la
nature parce que lorsque je revenais de
l'école mon grand-père avec quelques
fraises accrocher quelques feuilles de
kylie et les lorsque j'arrivais de
l'école je me jetais dans les perdent
dans les bras de mon grand-père qui
gardait les chèvres les moutons et je
manger des fraises des bois
manque que les fraises des bois on les
halles à paris et aujourd'hui vous êtes
un berger vous êtes en chef je suis
toujours un seul berger incroyable tout
ce tag origan exceptionnel
et l'ancien berger du village de manigod
là haut dans la montagne de zarat vi
reçoit à sa table les hommes politiques
les plus éminents les chefs d'entreprise
les plus prestigieux il a même eu aussi
la consécration
dix neuf et demi au gault et millau et 2
étoiles michelin pour des menus qui vont
de 300 francs à 1000 francs avec
quelques mondanités sans supplément
voilà pts que votre cuisine et une
cuisine scientifique je veux surtout pas
qu'elle soit scientifique elle et elle
est tout sauf certifie qu'elle est et
l'est absolument spontanée naturelle
parce que vous savez tout est là les
plantes sont là c'est très simple on
évite les fonds devront les fumeurs on
les remplace par des bouillons de
légumes
simplement parce que la plante a du mal
à absorber les des fonds elle absorbe
plus facilement bouillon de légumes sel
c'est un peu le principe de la de la
tisane que l'on prend le soir avant
d'aller au lit
vous avez dit tisane est ce que ça ne
vous rappelle pas quelqu'un les tisanes
vous êtes un peu à la rai
ne me parlez pas de show biz ou un loup
plaît les chemises marc veyrat on est
encore loin pour l'instant
d'ailleurs au coeur de son superbe hôtel
restaurant de luxe
il s'est construit un petit chalet
authentique situé tenez vous bien au
fond des cuisines pour les chaussées
c'est son jardin secret comme ça il
reste l authentique verger de manigod
j'ai toujours dit que ma vie grand la
haute-savoie c'était le plus beau pays
du monde
mais faut le dire en chantant la mayo si
vous voulez en savoir plus sur marc
veyrat et ses plantes et bien vous
pouvez lire son livre chez hachette foot
de saveur